I always think about you every year
because you're so great in that role you
were always up for the Emmy you and it
was also the years of Breaking Bad with
uh Brian Cranston you must [ __ ] hate
Brian granston
um I would think because winning the the
Emmy for your role would have you know
all those years that you were up against
him and he would win like he'd show up
he'd do whatever it is you'd have to do
to campaign for this thing in all
seriousness was it a bit annoying to see
him in Breaking Bad and like okay yes he
does a brilliant performance but give me
a [ __ ] break I'm doing something
pretty brilliant over here too I mean
had I never
had I never won for that role I think it
would have hurt a lot more but by the
end of it I actually did and and and I
you know I I thank Brian every day for
kindly bowing out by the end so I could
come in at the end
but no Brian I'm sure you've you've
you've interviewed him or talked to him
sure you know him you know he's he like
a lot like me had was kind of the
journeyman
guy for a long time I mean he was on
Seinfeld Malcolm for years you know and
and then finally gets this kind of
career defining role not unlike me and
um has has made the most of it he's the
he's the mensiest guy you'll ever meet
uh he came we had a screening of uh of
confess Fletch at a little screen room
here he showed up with his wife and you
know it was like he's he's I consider
him a really dear friend we've we went
through it you know I remember there was
a
it actually I brought I brought this up
when I last saw him but I was like we we
had a very early photo shoot
and it was for like AMC like they're
they're the new they're the new HBO
they're gonna come in they've got these
two shows that are gonna blow the doors
down and Mad Men was already a bit of a
hit
but Breaking Bad hadn't hadn't uh hadn't
done it yet so we're doing this photo
shoot and I'm in you know I'm in the
suit with the cigarette and the tie and
the hair slick back and Brian is in his
tighty whities
desert boots and a chemistry apron with
safety goggles and he just walks out
onto the onto the photo shoot thing he
looks at me and he goes I feel like I
got the wrong end of this deal yeah
you're looking all you're looking like
James Bond